[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed I wonder with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
and I did pops
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion people
every known
call this place home
but that doesn't mean they all like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom to ask
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might be able to
help us
you look rough
do not call me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job true king
builds Bridges right
King builds Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
it's the black Trident
we're in King outland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
it was a curse upon them all
we're trying to start magic is spreading
she means to end the bloodline
I don't know what I said but we can't
leave our children in a world without
hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
if you lead
Seven Kingdoms will follow
[Music]